it's difficult to find someone oblivious
to the World of Harry Potter for many it
was a property that grew up with them
with both the book and film series
persisting in the Zeitgeist for decades
it's confusing then that it's taken this
long to get a game that promises to
deliver on the fantasy of becoming a
wizard or witch within that Universe
attending classes learning spells
engaging in mischief and exploring the
Grandeur of Hogwarts Castle Hogwarts
Legacy delivers on that promise to a
degree its adaptation of this universe
is undeniably the most extensive yet
allowing you to truly explore Hogwarts
and its surrounding areas like never
before but it's also stuck too keenly in
the present and sometimes past of open
world game design reducing much of what
you do to repetitive checklist
activities in a world that is
disappointingly barren
foreign
Legacy takes place in the late 1800s
although you might be hard-pressed to
notice that from the way characters
speak or by the clothes they wear which
look ripped straight out of the film set
in the late 1900s you play as a prodigal
witch or wizard of your own creation
this time fighting against a goblin
Uprising led by one particularly nasty
one named ranrock this props up a
predictable and surprisingly sporadic
narrative with main beats and
progression only taking place every few
hours as you complete the requisite
quests around them which are often
barely related there's so little screen
time for many of the main characters
that you struggle to get a sense of
their motives especially so in the case
of ranrock who only appears to deliver a
line or two to some subordinates before
he disappears for a couple of hours it
robs him and the story of any sense of
emotional tension reducing it to nothing
more than talented good student takes
out bad powerful Goblin by the end while
trying to stop a potentially cataclysmic
Uprising you'll also be required to
juggle the duties that come with being a
newly inducted fifth year at Hogwarts
being both a new and older student means
you get to enjoy the throes of learning
some familiar spells from earlier years
but also have access to a wide range of
more advanced ones as the year
progresses you must be precise in your
wand movement we don't want you blowing
your hand off the initial introduction
to each class is captivating from
partaking in duels in defense against
the dark arts or being subjected to a
screaming Mandrake in herbology
these are some of the moments where
Hogwarts Legacy is at his strongest
recapturing the sense of wonder that has
made this world so enticing to so many
the mechanical components of each class
however fall woefully short the small
Mini-Game used to convey wand movements
for each spell feels ripped out of the
series's very first video game entry
nearly two decades ago while many of the
activities introduced shortly after are
brief uninteresting and usually used as
a means to fill up your map with many
more instances of the same thing they
quickly extinguish any glimmers of hope
that the school aspect of your time at
Hogwarts will be as engaging as many of
the classes might seem from the outside
after your introduction to each class
your engagement with each professor and
their craft is relegated to even less
interesting quests you're tasked with
completing two objectives before they'll
Dole out another spell with the chores
in question sometimes not even making
sense for the class they're required for
some you'll end up completing naturally
as you explore or engage with other
quests such as those that require you to
use certain spells on enemies or acquire
particular potions others will however
routinely force you to deviate from the
fun such as objectives that ask you to
either purchase or grow a particular
plant in the room of requirement which
can take upwards of 15 real world
minutes not too unlike the artificial
timers you'd find in a free mobile game
it was confusing to have progression
routinely stifled by these activities
given that most main quests generally
required a certain spell before they
could be started the growing collection
of spells is most useful in Hogwarts
legacy's combat which initially makes a
strong impression basic attack and
protection spells can be fight off with
ease with the combat flow mimicking a
familiar setup of timing blocks and
parries as you mash away at the attack
button in between Advanced spells sit on
a four slot weapon wheel allowing you to
cast them using one of the four face
buttons they're filtered into red yellow
and purple classes Each of which informs
you of their overall purpose in battle
purple spells such as Akio and descendo
are manipulation attacks that can
control and move opponents while red
spells such as the fire spell incendio
and disarming spells like Expelliarmus
are all about damage use intelligently
together combat has a rhythmic flow to
it that shines most when you're pulling
off combos flinging a foe into the air
firing off some basic attacks and then
suspending them there even further makes
you feel incredibly powerful but it's
also an effective way to take down
enemies that are happy enough to soak up
damage from your basic attack this way
of using magic is foreign to how it's
portrayed in the rest of the part of
verse media but it rarely feels out of
place here but there can be some
narrative dissonance if you Ponder on it
too long why are professors at Hogwarts
so comfortable with students fighting
thousands of dangerous goblins and dark
Wizards and witches just off school
grounds for example but it's easy enough
to suspend disbelief for the sake of the
satisfaction of getting to wield magic
so freely it's sometimes a bit too
jarring however notably when it comes to
the numerous unforgivable curses that
you'll have the chance to acquire while
they're still around letting you choose
whether you want to use them at all
there's nothing really punishing about
routinely using some of the worst spells
known to this universe
[Music]
so good characters might mention their
displeasure at you using them but it
never tangibly makes a difference to
proceedings letting them exist as just
another tool in your toolbox for when
you might need it as you continue
obtaining more spells you're forced to
assign them to Alternative loadouts with
a maximum of four once you've unlocked
them all the way you swap between each
of these loadouts and in turn reassign
which face buttons are assigned to which
spell is incredibly cumbersome outside
of combat you'll repeatedly have to dive
into a menu and rearrange which spells
are where since you'll quickly obtain
more than you can hold at a time
swapping between each one while fighting
also stifles the engaging rhythm of
fights and you can easily end up
fighting more against your memory of
which spells are located within which
Loadout then you do the threats around
you it ends up feeding into the
repetitive nature of combat because it
becomes far simpler to just stick with
the four basic spells that you never
have to navigate away from especially
since they scale generously with your
level and upgrades while enemies don't
really change meaningfully over the
hours you'll engage with dark Wizards
and witches along with dark goblins and
a variety of foreign ranging from rabid
wild dogs to gigantic web slinging
spiders despite the variety it's fairly
easy to approach each type with the same
strategy with only humans and goblins
presenting slightly more of a challenge
because of their color-coded Shields
which you'll need to destroy with some
appropriate spells larger enemies are
immune to the sort of juggling you might
have become comfortable employing on
smaller hapless foes but they diminish
any additional sense of danger they
could have presented by featuring a
grossly limited move set for attacks
this is even worse with bosses
especially those repeated at the end of
several key story missions who only have
two attack patterns you need to learn as
you slowly chip away at their health bar
the repetitive nature of these fights
makes you keenly aware of how they
artificially drawn out sapping any real
excitement from most of them almost
every Quest incorporates combat in some
way which doesn't help its repetitive
nature but many also give you chances to
use spells in less obvious ways with
your assortment of manipulative magic
Hogwarts Legacy trusts your intelligence
with spatial puzzles that sometimes had
me pausing for thought before arriving
at a satisfying conclusion the best
quests were ones that mixed this up
nicely with combat peppering a
multi-stage level filled with puzzles
with some brief fights to shake up the
pacing perhaps the best example of this
is an assault on falboton Castle which
featured a variety of high walls to
scale with combinations of levitation
and time freezing spells along with
smart combat Encounters in
uncharacteristically tight spaces where
a small misstep could be a long fall to
death it's capped off with a suitably
climactic scene where you take flight
atop a hippogriff for the first time it
swoops down a nearby Valley just as the
Hogwarts expresses traveling past
throwing up thick clouds of smoke as it
passes by it's a quintessentially Harry
Potter moment that feels ripped out of
the main Cannon and emphasizes the
attention to detail that Hogwarts Legacy
abides by In This regard
Mikasa
this attention to detail is most evident
throughout Hogwarts Castle Far and Away
the most engaging area of Hogwarts
legacy's expansive open world if you've
ever tried to piece together exactly how
all of its runes connect how staircases
that move around joined vital hallways
together or just where every little
Landmark is situated there hasn't been a
better way to get those answers to date
at times it feels like you're navigating
an engrossing Museum taking small stops
at places of magnificence such as the
great hall or the library seeing
students go about their day and small
acts of playful magic firing off in the
corner of your eye it's visually
gorgeous and inviting to pick apart but
also filled with small puzzles and
activities that further encourage your
exploration it certainly might not have
been big enough to contain the entirety
of Hogwarts Legacy story but its level
of Polish stand in stark contrast to the
world outside of its walls while
Hogwarts Castle is grandiose the only
other part of Hogwarts legacy's gigantic
map that comes close to matching it is
the vendor Laden streets of hogsmead
ignoring the same two vocal cues that
played every time I ventured there the
town itself is every bit as cozy as your
character will frequently suggest while
also providing vital Mercantile services
for all your potions equipment and more
the area surrounding both of these large
landmarks are disappointly Barren by
comparison The Forbidden Forest is
suitably Eerie at any time of the day
but its visual impact is impaired by all
the other identical forestry that
stretches across all of the surrounding
Hills smaller Villages appear throughout
the map too with a handful of merchants
and some side quests to accept in them
but these are even more cookie cutter in
their construction to the point where
it's almost impossible to tell one from
another as you're exploring nothing
makes us more evident than when you're
flying across the countryside on a mount
or broom while it's unsurprisingly easy
to pick out both Hogwarts and hogsmead
from a distance everything else Blends
into an indistinguishable blur of
Forestry and bear fields which really
invited me to explore it over fast
traveling between quests to be clear
there are things to do within this
visually drab open world but they're
usually just as uninteresting as their
backdrop Hogwarts legacies world is it
with an abundance of trivial activities
to complete the likes of which you'll be
familiar with if you've kept abreast of
modern open world designs there are
enemy camps to clear out flora and fauna
to either collect or hunt down pages
from your collectible Field Guide to
uncover chess behind locked doors to
rummage through and so much more it's
meant to alleviate the time spent
traveling to and from story missions
while also offering monetary and gear
rewards but it's so easy to overlook
entirely given how frequent those
rewards are handed out in far more
interesting main quests problems arise
however when Hogwarts Legacy forces you
to engage with these mediocre side
activities in order to progress many
story quests are gated with both level
and spell requirements the former
depending on your current numerical
level and the latter on whether or not
you have access to a specific spell
experience is only rewarded for many of
the activities thrown around the world
and the various albeit Bland side
missions you can complete depending on
how much you choose to explore Hogwarts
legacy's World organically or not you
can find yourself like I did frequently
forced to take a pause from the main in
path and work through open world
missions just enough to continue before
being faced with the same hurdle again
the Allure of better gear should offset
the monotony but so graciously handed
out by defeated enemies that you'll find
yourself rubbing up against your
restrictive inventory you start off with
20 slots that are shared across all five
of your gear categories which can be
filled within just one or two missions
if you're not making a habit of visiting
the merchant to offload items or
wastefully destroying them where still
is that the only way to alleviate this
issue is to complete countless Merlin
trials across the map all of which are
one of a handful of small quick puzzles
repeated Ad nauseam each milestone in
the quest rewards you with 4 extra slots
and the requirements to the next one
increases as you go making it a tedious
log if all you want to do is reduce the
frequency with which you have to manage
your inventory there's a sense of bloat
that permeates many of Hogwarts legacy's
mechanics informing design decisions
that turn into a familiar loop-based
action game there are so many systems
that exist solely to tempt you into
caring about maxing out your equipment
levels or upgrade trading gear to
enhance his stats both of which are
completely unnecessary in the face of
how little the challenge the combat
poses to keep up with you the room of
requirement a small Hub of Swords is a
space that lets you reveal unidentified
gear similar to Diablo or destiny craft
potions and cultivate violent Flora that
both feature long timers you have to
wait on before you can claim them and a
massive space for all your collected
beasts that can be formed for resources
vital to upgrading your gear aside from
the odd visit to complete a quest or
craft a single potion I felt little
reason to return to this space for the
many purposes it was designed for even
unidentified gear became mostly
irrelevant as better gear often in the
same Rarity class would drop before I
felt compelled to make the trip these
are some of the numerous systems that
Hogwarts Legacy pushes you to engage
with often forcibly through Quest lands
with many of them not coalescing with
the structure of the rest of the Game
ending up as Superfluous and a waste of
time time is something Hogwarts Legacy
and its repetitive quests dull open
world and monotonous combat do not
respect from its slow opening to its
insistence on introducing new systems to
juggle just for the sake of it it's a
bit of a shame that these parts don't
coalesce in the same way that its
presentation and respect for its
Universe does because Hogwarts Castle
persists as a delightful puzzle box to
explore from the moment you step foot in
its doors to the last day of term
there's equally delightful moments
during some of the main quests
specifically those that balance puzzle
solving and combat in ways that
challenge your understanding of the
Spells you have in engaging ways but
these moments are so spread out between
much less interesting filler content
that will likely take some of the most
dedicated Harry Potter fans to justify
seeing the entire journey through
camera
[Music]
Hogwarts Legacy is developed by
Avalanche software a subsidiary of
Warner Brothers interactive
entertainment the game has been
embroiled in controversy due to
transphobic remarks from Harry Potter
author J.K Rowling although she is not
personally involved with its development
she stands to profit from its success
for more on this please see this video's
description for a link to our in-depth
article on how Rowling's comments have
impacted the trans community in this
article you will also find links to
trans creators you can support as well
as Charities you can donate to